whoa
whoa
hold up his chin is breathing here we go
oh
what the heck wait
what
what
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to figure
out how you can get two free months of
premium membership
hey guys we're back it's bollywood time
we actually have no idea what any of
these people are saying but we know
there's a visual effect in there
somewhere i'm excited to hop in i have a
whole coffee in my system and i'm ready
why do i always have to be in the back
of the couch because you're the tallest
do you guys know i'm actually part
indian
i'm legit actually part indian sorry
exit point secured or contact me
dude this guy this guy's going to get
clipped this guy's going to get clipped
hard is this the home doom
oh he's undercover
wait he's suspicious he he is standing
on a manhole cover that is instantly
suspicious he's going in he's going down
i think he's going up
i don't think he's that old yeah he's
definitely not old that's makeup hold on
timeout all right votes is he going up
or down on that manhole cover i think
he's going down and then he's gonna
re-emerge anew oh that would be the
bollywood way oh man i think clint's
onto something here all right
here we go
he's only going one way
oh
what the heck wait what what what
that one
hold on what is the liquid oh no he's
going down that's acid the compound that
is horrible the white edges there's it's
so small it was just that first shot
though because the rest of the acid
actually looked not that bad
the left one is the one that's drawing
my eye because it looks like a video
co-pilot blood squirt blood squirt
turned green it looks like it's
splashing out as opposed to rolling
across the ground there the end of it is
actually disappearing it's the white
halo on them that really gets me but
then it cuts to the next shot where you
actually see the acid starting to pool
on the ground and now that is an actual
liquid simulation that we're seeing it's
actually not bad no i i agree and you're
getting that that like specular
highlight stuff going on it's the a-man
where did he go where did he go they're
like no oh my god he has fooled us she
fooled me too well wait oh he's coming
back
and he's old
he's decked out he's got a rubber blade
he's got roller
calling it god dang it i'm gonna go dude
clint you're right you just forgot the
rollerblades and he's got to do a trick
you have to do a trick and pose all cool
over those cars man because bollywood is
just a contest of how cool you can look
when you're in an action scene he had
his effects makeup artist take off his
face makeup oh hell yeah
this is
this is awesome
these shots are legit
dude he hits one pothole and he is done
they're doing a really good job at
making everything feel like it's at full
speed yeah
like the cars are moving at like a
normal highway speed the the wide shot
like those shots right there usually
when you fast forward stuff it has like
that very jittery motion that's very
easy to tell that something's been
fast-forwarded generally you're limiting
yourself to like 25 30 miles an hour if
you have like a human outside of the
vehicles yeah because the moment you
start going any faster with a person
there it's kind of like guarantee death
if something goes wrong so you always
have to find creative ways to kind of
keep things looking like they're moving
at a normal speed it's what they did for
matrix reloaded on the highway scene
everyone's just kind of driving at a
slow speed and as long as you keep the
camera steady and smooth enough you can
fast forward it and make it look full
speed without the shakiness coming in
oh
all right you got the helicopter team
they got the sniper cg helicopter whoa
whoa whoa whoa so is that full cg that
helicopter flying through the city there
it looks full cg to me it looks like a
2d card it was probably a real
helicopter filmed on a plate that they
extracted from that plate and put into
the scene and then animated it to come
closer to camera you can tell that
because the actual orientation of the
helicopter doesn't change as it goes
from really far away to close to camera
it stays the same
ren did that in real life
look at those muzzle flashes though yeah
the muzzle flashes in this are pretty
pretty beautiful i think that's a three
frame muzzle flash i just want to count
how many frames that thing is all right
one what a beautiful little muzzle flash
is just one it's all about like the tiny
like
lingering dust ball
now he's really gonna get them this time
the helicopter moves towards the left of
the frame whereas the little smoke thing
there literally doesn't move at all it's
like untracked yeah but they're also in
a helicopter moving sideways really
really quickly maybe that was an attempt
to make it look like it was flying
backwards you know kudos to them for
putting a reflection of the muzzle yeah
and they put lighting they put lighting
on the door and him they actually did
the proper compositing for this they
just got the scale of the muzzle flash
wrong it's still a beautiful little
muzzle flash i just wanted to let the
artist know we appreciate it hey nick
get ready to pan slash tilt to the trash
can oh my god settle your heart rate
guys i just finished this coffee all
right i'm gonna i'm gonna ace this right
into this trash can if i make it if i
make it you have to subscribe okay all
right here we go three two one
hey hey hey hey hey
keep it together clint if you're
subscribed if you're subscribed don't
unsubscribe
take a few deep breaths he totally
whipped the shot i can already your
heart rates are like 160. and like a
hamster my heart rate's like a freaking
hamster's heart let's go
a wall of flesh that's pulsing and a man
with a lantern i i love this by the way
i'm sold
that mustache
that shadow
this is great yeah this is cool
i don't care what it's about i'm down is
that genie
a dem a demon genie is he the genie is
this what the inside of a bottle looks
like
meat walls dude if i was a genie in a
bottle be pissed uh oh that's the
perspective of a creature
oh got him oh so scary actually i'm
super confused right now like this this
is just a set
this is just a meaty set there's no way
this is a cg set
oh
his chin is breathing oh man brutal
like the set's real and like there's
tons of practical makeup going on but
all that pulsing and twitching you see
is i'm pretty sure it's that's added in
later basically you're just applying a
little bit of distortion to give it that
like alive kind of movement yeah but
it's it's definitely done well it's
really subtle
uh oh monster man is the monster real
whoa or cg
dude that particle oh that's cg oh he is
cg wow this is great
what
what just sorry this is just getting
crazy is he pooping out coins making
that butt money okay it is a pouch i was
kind of confused what kind of opening
that was the set definitely looks
practical and that's when you can
compare the actual like the slimy factor
and the reflections off of the set to
the cg character they're very close the
lighting is actually really good on the
creatures the rendering is pretty good
but i feel like the material doesn't
quite line up to the set as well the
specular highlights are very broad and
kind of dim and going across like his
whole hand there his face there's
another shot where you see like some
actual physical prop guts and stuff the
highlights are way sharper and they're
way smaller and there's way more of them
whereas on the creature they're a little
bit dimmer a little bit more spread out
i see what you're saying totally when
you're building like a 3d material
generally you're given like a few basic
settings what's the flat color that
you're trying to render then you can
change the specular settings which
dictate how reflective certain things
can be you have another setting for
roughness which is for instance the
roughness of my watch face is basically
zero because it's reflecting everything
perfectly but you have the roughness of
maybe this bottle for instance and you
see how it's not a flawless pristine
reflection there's only so many
properties you can tweak but when it
comes to a character that's covered in
blood and dirt and is made out of skin
and has a crown you start to get into
these situations where you have a lot of
these different elements interacting in
really unique ways that when you just
try and apply like a single texture to a
creature you're not able to fully
capture what that would actually look
like yeah but i mean look at that shot
there what works in their favor so well
is the single point of light right in
the center of the scene all of the
monsters are actually lit really well
yeah i love it i'm just saying like
you're not seeing the right combination
all these properties trying to be forced
into one i i think a big thing that
throws off this effect for me is the
movement a little too perfect a lot of
it feels like it's animated by hand i
don't feel like they had a person with
like a mocap suit necessarily for this
it was more like they filmed someone
doing the actions probably did some
paint out and then had someone go in by
hand to recreate the character's motion
honestly like the monster work in this
movie is really solid yeah it looks
pretty freaking good to me this is a
really cool movie i kind of want to see
it i guess it's on youtube and you can
just go watch it right now if you want
sam is a great film we've actually gone
through this movie before but there are
more scenes to be discovered like the
whole genre of the indian maverick cop i
love it like india's version of
superheroes like captain america you
know except he's like captain india
oh no is he wobbling it i think he
wobbles for a good like minute
oh god here we go gonna
bonk them with a light post he's ready
to play some beat saber single arm beat
saber with a stack there he goes oh no
oh no
done dude deceased
whoa
whoa
hold up wait what that was real that
like
those were not cg people that was a real
stunt there obviously there had to have
been wires that they painted out
oh no more wire work
just the biggest nothing like that in
the back of the head to cause them to
fly up
oh he's like whoa
you can't this dude just outran a car
you can't outrun this dude here comes a
slab oh it's a slap is this the power
slap
oh no
[Laughter]
i love this
let's get back here
oh
yeah that last shot looked really weird
by the way that the top down one yeah
that something was up there yeah that's
fake yeah it's a perfect cutout of him
is this shadow a little smaller than him
it looks a little smaller yeah your
shadow's always going to be bigger i'm
fairly convinced now they didn't
actually shoot him spinning on that
ground they shot him somewhere else and
they had to put him into that shot so
they probably just tracked the ground
back in rotoscoped him turn that into a
shadow basically make him into a shadow
on the ground just slightly offset and
the effects done but they did a good job
with the ambient occlusion look at the
center of his shadow it gets darker it
works well enough for the moment it's
over in like half a second and then you
moved on you don't even remember that
you saw that shot somebody gonna get a
hook oh there we go there we go
granny style so these bollywood clips
are super inspiring and they inspire me
to get better at my vfx game and if you
guys are the same then i think today's
sponsor is actually perfect for this
episode it's skillshare and if you guys
don't know about skillshare it's
basically an online learning community
for creatives who are looking to up
their game so i've actually been using
skillshare over the last month and
patrick foley has a really great class
on creating realistic french fries in
cinema 4d and octane he actually goes
through the whole thing you model the
french fries you actually have ketchup
with a nice simulation going of salt in
the air and he lights it really really
well really really cool class skillshare
has thousands of classes they actually
make it really easy to get into they're
pretty bite-sized set for any schedule
they got classes on photography motion
graphics design filmmaking any skill you
guys can think of so lucky for you guys
skillshare is actually hooking you up
with two months free of a premium
membership to get you guys learning to
get your game stepped up and honestly
skillshare is super affordable less than
10 bucks a month for an annual
subscription now is the time to learn as
much as you can and this is a great way
to do so all you guys have to do is
click the link in the description below
for two free months of premium
membership and start exploring that
creativity we love reacting to bollywood
visual effects please leave a comment
down below we read all the comments and
we'd love to do more of these thank you
for subscribing we all appreciate it
here
i've imagined watching this and i had a
blast i can't afford to see movies but i
watched the vfx breakdowns on youtube
and that's pretty exciting
that's your character in a nutshell i'd
imagine the whole movie's quite nice if
you watch it